[Music]
we have to believe ourselves we have to
build believe our stories our culture
can resonate with a wider audience
across the world
and there is nothing else stopping from
nothing else that can stop us from doing
it he's a leading light in the telugu
language film business known as
tollywood a pioneer in a new southern
indian genre that's all about epic big
budget over-the-top action movies after
the big success of bhakbali
we were under a
certain kind of pressure what kind of
film that we should do to match the
success of these films
then
i came upon this idea of
taking to legendary freedom fighters of
indian freedom struggle
and putting them together and i found
that very very exciting and interesting
and my whole story team thought it was
fantastic and we jumped in one of the
most expensive indian films ever made
rrr proved a big hit at the box office
and if you're wondering where the name
came from
at the starting of the film we didn't
find a title we were still searching for
the title but for ease of communication
we named it rrr and everyone started
referring it to rrr so when we actually
put out a contest asking the people to
find it item for the film and they said
we already named it right it's already
right hollywood is now getting the edge
over its better known hindi language
rival bollywood making more money and
more impact in india's 24 billion dollar
media and entertainment market slowly
the producers realized in the north that
to make in
film that caters to all kinds of
audiences you need to put in big work
budgets
and if the film fails the risk factor is
high if the film succeeds the profit
margins are yes good
but if you make an urban centric film to
certain kinds of audiences the risk
factor is low you don't need to spend so
much
then
came back which cater to everyone and
we really push the boundaries higher
budgets bigger screen entertainment
hardcore emotions bigger action
sequences it had everything for urban
audience mass audiences everything and
it really blew up the two-part mythical
fantasy bahubali was filmed over 600
days here at ramoji film city the
world's largest film studio complex
so will his next project be on a similar
scale my ambitions
are already fulfilled in a way because i
wanted to make big epic scale war or
action and i have already done it but
the next big ambition is that
i want the indian stories to go across
the world and i really want to be at the
forefront of it that's my selfishness
[Music]